feel like they should sit out from this
and leave the room which is fine in
terms of Castle shenton
you've indicated something about you
being a ward member on one of those
projects can you just go a bit further
and explain which one and what action if
any you are considering taking
27 37.
oh yeah yeah okay that's the
problem okay
I see
so so can I can I just be clear uh Mr
Grafton does that mean councilor shenton
has to leave the room or not
it's it's really his decision he's
saying he's going to leave the room I
haven't been asked for any advice prior
to the meeting
um I I so so my my question is should I
leave the room I'm quite happy to leave
the room at that point
foreign
yes Council Parry
um chairman I just want to highlight
that I'm a member of the parish council
and the ward member for Morton moral
item number 28. it is on the reserve
list it is the smallest
application for funds of four and a half
thousand I don't feel that at a fund of
that level
um that I would still come with a
um an open I still feel I'm able to vote
on the overall thing because it is just
such a small sum and it is on the
reserve
aspect of the papers
so leader what I'm hearing is that in
the case of counselor Barker and
counselor Harvey not only is it about
the size of the project we're talking
about
um one and a half million pounds almost
but it's also because they've got a
connection with the project as patients
I doubt in the cases of the two issues
that councilor shenton and councilor
Parry have mentioned which are to do
with a playing field and play equipment
that they would be partaking in that
kind of activity I may be wrong but um
point of orders an ageist comment there
from the legal officer I I think what
you are saying Mr Mr Grafton is that
councilor Perry and councilor shenton
have no Escape
they are unlikely to be using those
facilities and also as counselor Perry
says that the size of those two projects
is relatively small at four and a half
thousand and just over five thousand
pounds are we clear where everyone is
good uh in that case uh minutes are
there any issues on the minutes
I'll take that as a no
so moving on item four allocation of
community infrastructure Levy uh sale
funds and I have to say when you look at
the papers you realize just how much
workers uh gone into this and I think we
should complement Joe on all the hard
work that's been put in councilor junid
and then councilor Cargill and I get to
introduce yes sorry yes I think I get to
introduce the item first uh just just to
let you know that I will be speaking as
Ward member for ulstertown on this
particular issue thank you councilor
Cowgill are you the same uh and others
fine
right so councilor Pemberton would you
introduce the report please thank you
leader thank you kindly
um members the purpose of the papers
before you is to establish uh how we are
going to distribute uh silmoney's
um for the uh year 2223
there is a recommendation there are two
recommendations to withdraw funds from
two allocated projects because they
frankly uh cannot be delivered in the
case of the Ulster scheme
um
clearly if that position were to change
for a future funding round there would
be no reason for that scheme not to come
back in
so we have sill funds of
2.65 2654 843 pounds
um allocated to 10 projects uh in
um
table three of this report I am going to
be bringing forward
um a further recommendation that I will
be seeking support from for cabinet
uh members will note that there are
three schemes on a reserve list
it is the view of officers and cabinet
or certainly my viewers portfolio holder
that
um it would
meet our
policy aspirations as an authority to be
able to spend money on projects as far
as is possible across the district and
also to disperse money both for Big
Ticket projects such as 1.4 million for
an NHS scheme to also support smaller
projects
um and I think that is a rational and
reasonable approach to the use of cell
Monies
um I am advised by officers
um that as at the end of January
um we have already collected for the
financial year
23-24 something around 1.1 million
pounds and we still have funds to come
in potentially between now and the end
of the financial year
um I am minded to recommend to Cabinet
indeed we'll recommend a cabinet that
there are three projects which
are on a reserve list that are worthy of
support from sill funds
there are clearly going to be funds
available uh the three projects involved
are valued at Circa 31 000 pounds
um it seems to me that it would not be
there is no great public benefits served
by making those projects wait for
another 12 months to secure funding when
there is more than sufficient funding
available to be deployed at the start of
the new Financial year without fettering
the decision-making of any future
Council
and indeed if one were to take a linear
approach of allocating spend for each
month would be you know each month is
Circa 130 000 pounds worth of available
budget so we are nowhere near
um touching the sides in terms of what
is available and I see no prospects that
we could be in a position of fettering
this Council for
sill decisions next year and on that
basis I am going to recommend a fifth
recommendation that the schemes on the
reserve list
be funded and that those schemes be
green lit from
the immediate start of the new Municipal
Financial year
and those schemes be allocated the sums
that are claimed totally in just over 31
000 Parts
with that I'll defer to any questions
observations firstly from cabinet
members and then clearly our observers
have also indicated as Ward members and
a wish to to speak
foreign
thank you very much indeed when I heard
about this I asked the chief executive
officer to immediately arrange a phone
call for me a meeting with me for the
environment agency
and that is now taking place on March
the 8th which was the earliest that the
environment agency could meet with me
I just want to make the case that Ulster
has been very badly hit by flooding in
the past with approximately 121 houses
flooded in the most recent inundation
but there's been several of those uh
over many many years
in 2001 the flood defenses for
two-thirds of the Town were upgraded to
the original 1950s standards but about
one-third of the flood defenses were not
able to be upgraded at that time and
that is what we are talking about
there is a site for Extra Care housing
which is unable to be developed until
the flood defenses on the remaining
one-third of the town's flood defenses
are is upgraded to at least a reasonable
standard at least a minimum of the 1950
standards if not to more modern
standards
into in an anticipation of future
climate change it is imperative that the
flood Defense work does proceed for
Ulster I would like to see a delay until
such time and as the ward members myself
and councilor Cargill have had the
chance to speak in depth to the
environment agency as to why there is
this delay in case there is a way of
proceeding to make sure that this could
take place it would be absolutely tragic
if because of a delay by this from this
money but also from the environment
agency if there was another flood
um it would happen in Ulster meanwhile
we do need to proceed as fast as
possible I'm just asking for a two-month
delay until we can have had this chat
with the environment agency to find out
what it what else could be done thank
you
uh thank you councilor junid I I think
in the case of oh
councilor Cargill thank you I'd like to
reiterate what council June had said
obviously I put this into the bad timing
award category
uh the bad timing award category because
we've been working closely with both
Mauritius County Council on the extra
care facility and also the environment
agency unfortunately there are multiple
Personnel changes which stored the
project now we have got some more
certainty with the officers and I'm
quite I'm extremely hopeful that we can
actually come up with a viable scheme
for this particular defenses
I said as as I've been said you can't
overemphasize how important this is and
a delay and I understand the frustration
we have been putting it's been in the
pop two years and it hasn't been come
forward so there's there's no real
excuse but it is just bad timing at the
moment and I'd appreciate it if we can
delay putting this money back into the
pot
until we have had that meeting with
environment agency and got some
certainty and brought it back to Cabinet
if I may
and also just
um I please respond to that if you wish
there are a couple of other items I
would like to just to briefly touch on
thank you
councilor Pemberton do you wish to
respond yes thank you leader
foreign
and because the short the short answer
is no because our officers and the chief
executive of this or of this Authority
have had dialogue with the environment
agency and frankly they just can't get
themselves sorted out
and I am not prepared to put other
projects
on hold across the rest of this District
while the environment agency get
themselves sorted out they have had more
than two years to do this and frankly
they have given everybody the run around
here now if councilor Junaid and
counselor Cargill you can unlock that
Log Jam as I said in my introduction
this money can go straight back into the
pot for next year
you know this is a slam dunk in terms of
its priority but I am not prepared to
make other projects suffer and there are
projects that would fail
if we do not make a decision on funding
so I'm I am quite adamant on this to
both of you we have worked this through
we have charged up to chief executive
level in this organization and frankly
the environment agency have been tardy
to say the very least this is not a big
ticket project for the environment
agency don't even touch the sides as as
I said earlier about the reserve list
um
bluntly I don't have any confidence that
you two would be able to come back to me
in two months time and say we've got it
I've seen no evidence whatsoever of
Engagement by the environment agency to
bring this forward and deadlines Drive
Behavior
and if
the environment agency are wedded to
this project then they've got a new
deadline I'm not prepared to move on
this and I do not recommend a cabinet
that we do I absolutely support and
understand and I do see you know the
need for the project and the climate
change applications
but frankly two months isn't going to
make any difference whatsoever you have
a categoric assurance that there's you
know we know what the cost of the
project is if they get themselves sorted
out it goes in the list and whilst I am
not in a position to Fetter the
discretion of a future Authority
um I personally would be minded if we
got to a position and if I were the
decision maker involved halfway through
this calendar year that this could be
Revisited
for an allocation
rather than actually wait till this time
next year I would be happy to do that
but I am not prepared to risk the other
projects and there are projects at risk
so it is a flat no in terms of
recommending that to Ken to Cabinet I'm
sorry councilor junid I am not asking
for a delay to the rest of the project
I'm asking for a delay on a decision for
this one specific project and I think
it's because
um the uh because there's been so many
um so much
um uh staff changes at the environment
as you see it's fallen through I I
really do I've taken part in workshops
uh and I know cancer cargo has had a lot
of conversations and I think it's me it
is possible for it to be happen we are
not asking for a delay to any other
projects we're asking for this 200 000
to be kept in the pot the reality is the
council adjunied if we keep this 200 000
in the pot then we have delayed or
canceled other projects so the reality T
actually is I think councilor Pemberton
is absolutely right I think there is a
perfectly sound principle that if other
bodies cannot get their act together
then the funding does not go to those
particular projects
Mr chairford
uh thank you leader
um just to give um because Junior and
Cargill some comfort so the the normal
timetable for the sale spend is is
normally the Autumn of the of the Year
we're delayed this this time so for 2023
I'd expect decisions to be made this
Autumn so it wouldn't be a full 12 month
period you have to wait for so hopefully
we can get this resolved and then you
know in you know six to nine months
we've got Clarity and we can then make a
decision that's you know the right
decision from your perspective
thank you
councilor Cargill
well I do appreciate the frustration
um you've probably experienced 10 of
what I've had over the last
four or five six ten years now with them
however it is greatly frustrating that
for the first time we are now at a point
where we actually believe that we can
get something done may I ask
then they did counselor Pemberton saying
that we can actually uh fast track this
if we get the right funding in place
from the environment agency is that
something that would be taken forward
I can only give you a personal
commitment
um
we have elections in May cancel the
cargo who knows who's going to be sat in
this holding this portfolio at that
point you know the you know the will of
the people Etc and there is a
well-established principle of not
fettering the decision-making of another
Council I think that the the proposition
around the reserve list is of such small
magnitude that that's not an issue but
certainly a two hundred thousand pound
spend and I'm getting a nod from the
legal officer would definitely be in the
fettering however having said that you
have that as my view and I would
struggle to see how anybody would
credibly come along and sit where I am
and come to a different conclusion about
fast tracking this project that is
however a personal View and other views
are of course available
so I can only give you the assurance
that where I in the position to make
that decision uh I would be Keen to
exercise that discretion I can't give
you any more than that
thank you
I would point out that in the narrative
there remains a funding gap of 1.3
million and I would not be surprised
given the inflation in Construction and
building the daf funding Gap is now
greater but nevertheless it's a
worthwhile project but at the moment it
can't just cannot be delivered and
that's the bottom line
oh I see no further hands no further
questions so we've got the
recommendations on page nine plus the
councilor Cargill yeah I I'm I did want
to just pick up a couple of the other
items in table three I will be brief um
I know that these are down for for
recommendations uh the natural flood
Management on the on and arrow River
catchments are very worthwhile project
and I'm involved on that one uh
certainly The Village Hall in wixford I
think that'll make a huge difference to
the community there and I'm very very
hopeful that that won't go through and
finally the arrow and even Greenwell
this is only one part of this project
and it's Cross County it's cross
district and so it's like it's a big big
project they're starting it small
they're doing one or two sections at a
time and this will make a huge
difference to it so again I'm very
hopeful that this will go through thank
you and can I endorse that because I've
also been to the arrow and even
um even an arrow Greenway project
meetings and I they they are a very very
well organized group and I think they
will stick to their commitments thank
you
thank you I think one comment that is
worth making there was a total cost for
the projects that were identified as
high priority of a Mia 16 and a half
million
and we actually have about
2.7 million to allocate and I think that
really sets the context for all of this
so without further Ado then the
recommendations on page nine plus the
additional recommendation that councilor
Pemberton has outlined uh are members of
cabinet happy with what is now five
recommendations in total
really
thank you members of cabinet so uh I
believe councilor Harvey and councilor
Barca will now rejoin the meeting
which is not easy to do though
right
well welcome back councilor Barker so we
are now moving on to item five the wells
born University Innovation campus
framework master plan supplementary
planning document which is a bit of a
mouthful
so councilor Pemberton once again it's
you
thank you leader
um what you have before you is uh the
work particularly of Matthew Neal and I
would like to place on record my thanks
for Matthew for what I believe is an
excellent piece of work and I am
wholeheartedly in support of the
recommendation
um the the plan is that
um and to give some context
members will be aware that the
um
former HRI site at wellsborn is now in
the ownership of the University of
Warwick and forms what they now call
their Innovation campus and that talks
about how they bring research and
development and near-market projects to
fruition and they are working closely
with other
bodies and private sector organizations
and already
there is a significant
influx of particularly
high-end
cutting-edge technology businesses and
businesses particularly in r d around
the automotive sector such as Lotus who
are now occupants of the Innovation
campus
there is the prospect
alongside wells-bourne Airfield which
we'll discuss shortly
and opportunity to create
a world-class
high-end university-based
Advanced r d
site that alongside the Airfield has the
opportunity to create
real
high-end high value High worth jobs in
this District
to help this District
regain and maintain the place that it
has held prior to the pandemic of being
the fastest growing part of the economy
of the West Midlands
and to create a better future for our
residents in terms of employment and
education opportunities and so the
supplementary planning documents
creates a framework and has been
discussed at Great length and in detail
with the university and other
stakeholders to actually
manage the development of the Innovation
campus to ensure that our residents get
the best possible outcome from a
world-class University to provide
world-class research development and
employment opportunities in a
world-class district and I would
absolutely recommend recommendations one
and two to cabinet and happy to take any
questions or observations from cabinet
in the first instance thank you
councilor Parry
thank you leader I would just like to
add my thanks and also congratulations
to our team of officers who have worked
very closely with the University of
Warwick in the development of this plan
I think what really stands out is the
attention to detail
and the vision
and the big planning approach where
there's been no stone unturned
um having been part of a number of or
certainly one of the Intensive workshops
where all stakeholders Parish councils
were invited
it is exemplary and demonstrates that if
one is going to produce a supplementary
planning document then this is a first
class and is best practice in being able
to communicate to all stakeholders so
they feel included and also their
opinions are taken into consideration
and I think particularly of interest is
the detail that has been done through to
the landscaping and the drainage
as I say no stone unturned on this
particular document and my thanks to
Matthew Neal and the team
um for for putting this forward and I
would certainly second the portfolio
holders uh recommendations thank you
leader thank you councilor Perry and I I
think you raised some very interesting
points
um we have had a lot of really good
cooperation with the university and I
think what you see here are the
dividends of that close working
relationship
so I see nobody else wanting to comment
councilor junid
um in many many years ago I actually did
research base work here or rather with
some of the original team mainly in the
um the planting environmental Sciences
area so I this is before it became part
of the Warwick University it was the
Horticultural Research Institute at that
time so I know the site well and uh I
think it would be most beneficial to be
a under Warwick University as an
invasion campus and I I applaud that
just one question
at the time there used to be a one a
world leading seed bank based on that
site and I'm just wondering whether that
is still on the site or whether that has
been removed to another site because it
was
um quite it was quite a unique uh site
that I I worked with at that time it is
still there councilor June good and it's
not only that but I leave I believe the
fields where they have the records of
everything that has been put on them
since 1947 remain Untouched by the
development
in which case I have no other questions
I actually do applaud that this is being
developed in the way it has been
developed
thank you for your applause councilor
Junior this is much appreciated uh
recommendations on page 49 members of
cabinet are you happy with those
recommendations
thank you members of cabinet to move on
now to uh when I turn over the update on
Wells Mall Airfield councilor Pemberton
once again
thank you very much leader and I and I
hope to enjoy the sound of further
Applause from councilor junid on this
item as well
members of cabinet will be aware of the
long ongoing questions around the future
of wells-bourne mountfield Airfield
um some years ago it became clear that
the landowners had aspirations
to redevelop the Airfield for an
entirely residential
development something of north of 1200
homes
not in accordance with the current core
strategy
um wrong place wrong time wrong solution
um
this Council resolved to establish a
policy position to preserve and enhance
flying functions
at wellsbourne Airfield under policy as9
and also chose and voted to
set aside funds
to ensure that if a
suitable and acceptable development
proposition did not come forward by the
landowners that this Authority would
seek to use its CPO powers to acquire
the site to ensure our policy position
was preserved and that the site was
operated and developed in a way that was
beneficial to Residents and The Wider UK
economy
and I'm delighted to say that I think we
are a long long long way down that track
um we are now in the position where
um the developer
sorry the landowner has
on the face of it and I I'm adding
caveats here accepted that the
development future for this site is not
residential
and the developer sorry the landowner
rather has bought into
our vision
of the site supporting the wells-bourne
campus by providing high-end employment
and Manufacturing base and an enhanced
Airfield
to support the Innovation campus
where we appear to be is that
through the hard work of particularly
Tony perks and
other officers and I have had a number
of discussions
um to try and bring this to fruition we
are in the position where there is a
broad agreement about the development
envelope and proposal which would
involve the reciting of the runway for
the runway to maintain what is called
code 2 status in short it's still as as
good a Runway as it's got at the moment
there are already small business Jets
particularly Munster joinery who bring
people in and it's vital that their
senior people can come in and out there
to keep that business moving
other businesses who are already on the
campus
have and and potential future occupy
occupiers of the campus
have indicated requirements for use of
the Airfield when the aviation is not uh
in train
and there is an opportunity to support
the Innovation campus by developments
next door
the developer the landowner has now
identified a development partner
and the next stage is likely to be well
the next stage will be some public
consultation events probably in Spring
early summer with a view to refining a
planning application to come in the
summer or potentially Autumn of 2023.
all of that is fantastic news this is a
good news story this is another
opportunity to create good quality jobs
to diversify and to deepen our economy
deepening it into key areas such as
agritech and Automotive but to bring new
areas in such as drone technology the
opportunity to create a drone Hub
servicing
the transport of organs between the QE
in Birmingham the QE Nottingham
University Hospital Coventry and the
John Ratcliffe in Oxford to create a
drone Super Highway for the transfer of
organs is a huge potential development
and could be the first of its kind on
that level within the NHS and that would
be in this District it is a great
opportunity
um so the the so councilor Jun Ed to
come to your inevitable question why am
I recommending that we keep the thick
end of a million pans back to continue
with the CPO the answer is we're just
not quite there yet
and whilst I am really optimistic and
the members will know that I am
generally a half full person it would be
inopportune and inappropriate to
um
release These funds until we're over the
line but I absolutely do have the hope
that these funds can be released in the
next financial year to do other good
things in this District
we have moved an awful long way
um
but Ronald Reagan once said trust but
verify and my verification is the thick
end of a million pounds still to put CPO
in place if we need to do it and
actually it strengthens our CPO position
because we now have a credible plan in
front of us that could be delivered
which develop develops a hugely improved
benefit to the public than the original
potential for a residential scheme so
it's a great scheme but now's not the
time to put the money back in the
coffers so my recommendation is that the
but the report is noted and that the
budget is maintained and when we're in a
position where we're absolutely certain
that this thing is over the line then
that money will go back in and we can do
good things with it
Council unit yes I had two questions and
one was uh the happy answer one was
about when when uh will the public be
and residents be consulted uh to make
sure that they are supportive of this
because they do need to be supportive of
it
um before to go ahead and the second one
was about the 800 000
um that has been set aside for the the
CPO
um and once that once you've got to the
stage when that CPO it money is no
longer needed
um I would like to know that it's been
put back into the budget because I'd be
interested to find out if I could get
200 000 for the Ulster flood defense
scheme thank you thank you councilor
Junior councilor Parry
thank you leader
um firstly I'd like to endorse councilor
pemberton's introduction and
um words about the project and also to
endorse my thanks to Mr Tony perks
whilst I'm not the ward member for the
wellesbourne Airfield or in fact
actually the wells-bourne campus area
um I can perhaps give an element of
reassurance to councilor junid that the
fact that this is going to be for
economic development
um certainly has been welcomed to those
residents I've spoken to on the doorstep
throughout wellsborn and actually the
adjacent Villages who are just totally
relieved that we haven't got 1200 1200
to 1500 new homes coming into wellsborn
so that's very very welcome I think it's
also a great lesson in terms of you know
it takes a long time to get the right
project at the right time and I think
you know yes this has been more than
four years
but it has been four years worth waiting
for
um and we have campaigned very very
diligently we've kept councilor pempton
has spent a lot of time communicating
with residents attending various events
at the Airfield and I thank you for your
time out of hours trying to communicate
keep residents informed of what we're
doing and every month at wellsborn
Parish Council I have been in a position
to give an update
um
there are very few really outstanding
airfields left in England and I feel
very proud and pleased that we're going
to have one of the best airfields in
England actually delivering High Caliber
jobs to encourage younger professionals
to come into Stratford District so my
thanks to you all
thank you councilor Perry some extremely
good points made I have councilor
shenton then councilor Cargill then back
to Council of Pemberton thank you leader
um more of a
observations and comments really I'd
like to thank obviously the portfolio
holder for updating us uh the deputy
lead of updating us on this um this has
been uh quite a long and and uh
challenging project to say the least and
but it shows that persistence
pays off and this is a a fantastic
example of how a plan is coming together
with the campus and with Wells broad
Airfield and what's uh gratifying as
well is to see that the uh one of the
the issues is that the code 2 Runway of
917 meters is is actually the length of
the runway uh as it is at the moment so
it it we're preserving uh Aviation there
and we're also encouraging new
Innovative industry such as the drones I
I just think that all the officers and
the portfolio holder Deputy leader
should be congratulated for this this is
superb and great news
thank you councilor shenton councilor
Cargill thank you I think at least four
years ago isn't it when we had this
original Vision at least when then the
the tie up with the University of
Warwick and here what I would like to
say is one thing only I'm glad this
Council held its nerve because I think
that's what took this as far as it's got
today holding their nerve on this one
keeping the CPO in place because that
showed the resolve of this Council well
done
thank you councilor Cargill councilor
Pemberton
um thank you councilors parry shenton
and Cargill for your kind words
um I've lived and breathed this thing
for the last four years
um and there's been an awful lot of work
the officers have played a complete
Blinder and you're right we have had to
keep our nerve and I have
personally had to look people in the eye
and make them believe that we will do
this thing
um I think I managed to persuade them of
that that I wasn't somebody who would
just back down that's a good thing
specifically to answer councilor
junaid's Point around consultation yeah
absolutely right and throughout this
process I have attended public meetings
that have been organized by
supporters of individual organizations
who have been users of the Airfield I
have attended meetings of the
wells-bourne matters group I've attended
three of their agms I have given updates
to the parish council and I know that
the ward member and adjoining Ward
members have been keeping the parish
council and their residents up to date
with
developments clearly public consultation
can only really start when you have
something to consult upon
but the direction of travel
um is absolutely where I understand the
residents of wellsborn want this site to
be so I can give the assurance that
there has been
a huge amount of communication and buy
in sort from the local resident
stakeholders and residents through
elected conservative members who work
locally and work really hard just want
to get that one in there and and Danny
worked really hard and have been part of
this process so the public
this will not come as a surprise the
last Wells born matters AGM I attended
in
this yes early December one Wednesday
evening
um was very well attended and I I gave a
a sort of slideshow presentation of
history and where we were at and I spent
about an hour and a half answering
questions from residents about
everything relating to wells-bourne
Airfield
um and I had no pushback whatsoever from
anyone about this as a as a future
uh outcome for the Airfield so I feel
confident that we are in a good place
that we've got a scheme that can really
deliver a huge benefit for this district
and for the people of wellsborn
and what's not to like so Q Applause
counselor Jeanette
thank you councilor pen mutton I'd just
like to reinforce a few of the points
that have been made
one was that if you actually look at uh
six one on page 128
the first reported cabinet came on the
11th of March 2019.
each taken is four years of hard slog to
get to where we are today
uh the point being made about keeping
our nerve was absolutely right there are
some really fraught meetings
and the million pounds we actually put
in for CPO made it all possible there's
absolutely no doubt about it
and what we have to remember is that
when the developers came forward first
it was for 1200 houses which
didn't fit with the core strategy and
didn't fit with the Wellsboro
neighborhood development plan
and we stood our grounds to defend the
position of the core strategy and the
neighborhood development plan and that's
how we've arrived at where we are today
and when you combine as has been said
the Airfield development with the campus
development it is a huge opportunity for
the district
so with that can I move to the
recommendation on page 125 the report be
noted and the budget to fund the
compulsory purchase order is maintained
can I have your agreement members of
cabinet
thank you members of cabinet
moving on the draft South Warwickshire
economic strategy councilor Parry thank
you leader
this report represents the draft
economic strategy for South Warwickshire
which has been prepared jointly by
officers from SDC and Warwick District
Council and needs to be approved for
public consultation by both SDC and
Warwick District Council cabinets
it has been produced as a five-year
strategy for the development of the
South Warwickshire economy and is
inspired by the range of Common Ground
opportunities which both SDC and WDC
face
it also reflects the benefits of shared
working practices in drawing up a common
Vision with ambitious plans and actions
to deliver this South Warwickshire
economic strategy by 2028
subject to your approval it is proposed
to launch the consultation next Friday
the 17th of February and comments can be
made until Friday 31st March 2023 via
either of the two councils websites
the main objective of this strategy is
to coordinate economic growth activities
across South Warwickshire and highlight
South warwickshire's significant and
contribution to the wider Regional and
National growth plans
my thanks are extended to John careford
and his team at both SDC and WDC for all
their hard work and the strategies
supported by a comprehensive supporting
evidence report and I hereby urge you to
approve the recommendations of this
report in order to progress to the
public consultation stage thank you
foreign
thank you I am absolutely delighted to
Second the recommendation uh and this is
an excellent piece of work and comes
forward to dovetail with the joint work
done on the South Warwickshire local
plan and he's again further evidence of
taking a holistic approach to all
matters as they relate to development
and I would like to thank John careford
and Joe and the rest of the team because
they've taken this piece of work on at a
point when the local plan is at a really
heightened states of work because they
appreciate the importance of us taking
the rounded view about how we move
forward and I think there to be I would
just want to Echo that cast of Paris
comments about the work that they've
done on this at a time when they've got
the local plan because it's absolutely
the right thing to do is to run the two
and make them dovetail together
thank you councilor Pemberton councilor
junid
um I did it I actually
um emailed the chief executive at some
stage asking for a briefing on this but
also for an invite for either myself or
another member of my group to the launch
because I believe that
um you know they this should not be one
particular party doing the launch
um so it would be useful if somebody
could just take that up again and see
whether an invite to the launch could be
um given to to might want somebody from
my group possibly myself I think I have
agreed that with the chief executive
unfortunately he's not ahead to the
Council of unit councilor shenton yeah
just a couple of miners a very minor on
page three of the document
um
h
it's probably right it's just sort of
stuck out and the travel time is by rail
for stretch
greater than the travel times by Road
Stratford to Birmingham I'm not saying
that's wrong just look
just wanted to double check that and
also then on Page Six
there appears there's a a gap where it
says image to be inserted so it's a
minor thing
they are minor it's just observations
other than that I think it's a great
document actually
thank you councilor shenton uh I'm sure
Mr careford will come on the on the
travel times but I think a lot depends
on how fast you drive councilor shenton
I I drive well under that you know well
under the limit okay uh
I think one should not underestimate the
importance and the significance of
having an economic strategy because if
you go back and Link it to the uh papers
that we've had on the wells Bond campus
and the paper we've had on wilsborne
Airfield
the reality actually is we will need to
use all three of these together to
attract inward investment into the
district to ensure we become even more
prosperous and have a more balanced
economy
so I think this is a brilliant piece of
work I think it is terribly easy to
underestimate the significance of a
piece of work like this and having a
Southward economic strategy is of
immense benefit to South Warwickshire
and the Stratford District
so without further Ado then the
recommendations on page 129 the full
recommendations there our members of
cabinet happy with those recommendations
thank you members of cabinet so we now
move on to the report from
overview and scrutiny committee and in
the absence of councilor Crump I believe
you will be doing this Council of unit
uh yes indeed I have been asked to do
that there were a couple of issues that
were raised at the ovian scrutiny uh the
ovary and scrutiny
um were supportive of the tree packs for
Farmers they recommended to the cabinet
uh that 30 000 from the climate change
budget be utilized for the scheme they
did raise some issues about money
wanting to see that they were properly
you know the properly meant the
maintenance was
um undertaken properly and did draw
attention to the to the fact that there
are similar schemes uh run by defra
County Council and Woodland trust and
wanted to make sure that this was
complementary and not replacing those
on the budget task and finish group
there was a recommendation for approval
for the Amendments that the cabinet
proposals and the Amendments from the
liberal Democrats as presented to the um
to the meeting
um but they did ask that a letter from
the local government Association to the
chancellor uh that was from councilor
Jamison who is the leader of the local
government Association to the chancellor
of the exchequer uh be noted because it
did draw attention to the some of the
facts that um government has rather a
short-term approach to Local Government
funding and a few other things like that
um there was a question an answer
session with councilor Harvey and and
that covered a range of problems a range
of issues but one of the problems that
was under uh noted was the difficulty in
recruiting accountants uh and some of
the problems with variation of income
for example car parking and the other
interest rates and other things that
were affecting the the budget
one at the end there was a cost of
living presentation from the
Warwickshire rural community council
Trussell trust food bank said citizen
advice this was probably one of the best
and most impactful presentations this
overview and scrutiny committee has had
for a long long time and it did draw
attention to the fact that
um use of food banks has absolutely shot
up that warm spaces were needed and that
there is considerable pressure on
residents
um from
meeting finances meeting and their
energy bills and that the council tax
areas and homelessness are big issues
and that there there is more need for
qualified staff and volunteers for the
citizen of advice
they were also drawing to attention to
the fact that counselors can help by
referring and signposting to all the
organizations that can give information
um to Residents but it was a very
impactful presentation it really Drew
attention to the fact that we have
severe problems even in an area that's
as well off as South Warwickshire we do
have considerable problems amongst our
residents over this last winter
the only other point that was raised was
about the sill spend one thing they did
say there was that they thought they
should be a better system for monitoring
and checking in on projects but that was
the only comment they made on that one
thank you
uh thank you councilor junid and uh can
I just say that the report produced by
councilor Crump uh presumably you are
proposing that be recommended cabinet
can I have a second to please
councilor shenton thank you so are
people happy with the report contained
in the papers be presented to cabinet
and the findings adopted Etc
kind of agreed thank you thank you
members of cabinet so we now move on to
the
the unblock items
are there any issues in the unblock
items non-worries with me beforehand
so they are all uh accepted
uh are there any is there any urgent
business
there is none no urgent business so
therefore I declare the meeting closed